Today, I announce
my first proclamation.
She got the throne.
Empress Catherine the Great!
Huzzah!
ALL: Huzzah!
ELLE: I think a big theme
of the show this year
is that she's becoming
a mother herself
and also becoming
a mother to Russia.
Look at you.
-At that thing.
-I call it the baby.
She's obviously
trying to juggle a lot.
It must be strange,
a human creature inside you.
Do you ever think,
what if he has a knife?
I never do.
And I don't think at first
that Catherine
necessarily takes to it.
Very odd to feel your lungs
being crushed
like an accordion
into your throat
by a foreign invading creature
who's taken over your body.
I think if God really
loved women, we'd lay eggs.
Catherine being pregnant
is clearly a feminist issue.
Are we almost done?
I have a great deal to do.
MARIAN: It has not affected
her ability to rule
in any way at all.
Anyone in the room
may congratulate me
on my diplomatic victory!
Huzzah!
The growing
creature within her
is the growing realization of
what it means to run a nation.
Will you retire
to bed now, Empress?
No, I have work to do.
That is why I am here.
Catherine's pregnancy affects
her strategy politically.
I have a busy day
running Russia,
the country
I just took from you.
She knows that while
she's pregnant, she's safe.
Everyone expects you
to last a year.
I'm safe until the baby is born.
This heir's coming and someone
could take the baby
and try and usurp her power.
Peter could come and slit
my throat and take over.
Imprisoned until Paul is born.
You're a good dad.
Look how big you are.
How's Paul?
We call the baby Paul.
My patience is wearing thin.
Love you. Bye Paul.
She's a very
progressive person
in a very conservative country
that doesn't really
want to change.
Let us remake Russia,
my friend.
So she's trying
to bring enlightenment
to a country that kind of
doesn't want to change
before she gives birth.
We must act fast and show
that I am a great leader,
indispensable,
destined, and loved.
Because she thinks after
I give birth, I might die.
Once Paul's out,
someone will try and kill you,
steal the baby,
and coup us both with it.
ELLE:
That's a big responsibility.
People spilled blood for us
and we will repay it
with sweat and toil.
Catherine is actually
a contemporary woman.
Well done.
I will act decisively
for my country.
Your arrogance is breathtaking.
My ambition is breathtaking.
You actually see her
in different phases of pregnancy
with her growing stomach.
Also, you know,
the pains of pregnancy.
-Oh. Yes.
-Did Paul just kick you?
All while she's trying
to lead a country.
I need to rest.
Not that she can't do it all,
she can.
-Of course, she can.
-Because I am the future.
You have never seen
a ruler like me before.
I will forge this country
into a progressive nation
that electrifies Europe and the
world as to what is possible.
God, I love your fire.
You are a wonder.
♪ ♪